over the big group of people today we're
going to high score camp which is where
they are doing the ice scoring drilling
project Oh Parker tubes is what we true
as what we've drilled this year um and
that was when we were in the brittle ice
so it's fragile ice and put it in some
green netting in case it pops or breaks
so this will sit over a year and then
we'll come back and process it next year
but just yesterday we started actually
processing the ice it turned out that
it's sturdy enough that we can cut it
and it won't bust into a million pieces
so that's what you'll see in like 30
seconds up there so probably want to
head up because we can see the drill
coming out of the hole I mean there's a
slicer
this is so dramatic
Wow
1120 metres thank you yep what is the
back to get all the liquid off the table
okay looks like just a long candy bar
like it
oh man those are the cutters
so the piece of ice that they just
pulled out was pulled out from about a
little over a thousand meters below the
surface of the of the snow here and they
think it's about twenty thousand years
old that that snow was deposited twenty
thousand years ago it's pretty cool and
then this stored here and then after
storing it here supposedly they ship it
to a place where they study the ice the
bubbles in the ice and the water and the
dust this is the motor instrument
section okay this is essentially the
brain okay okay then what you do with
them
okay okay spin out all the fluid capture
that okay back down whoo so where's 1100
this means like sort of 20,000 nice and
oh man it's super exponential live yeah
as you go to 16,000 to 1600 meters yeah
50,000 years old pretty cool that's
pretty amazing
I got old turnaround time from taking
the drill down drilling bring it up and
clean it up process it and put it back
down it's been about one hour and 15
minutes okay this is by far the slowest
part of the process stripping down
tripping up and go a lot faster
I'll get my priority
this is all this sludge that all the
chips looks like vanilla ice cream
this is really cool it's a vacuum
cleaner that has this shape of the core
you can't buy that from Hoover
it's so cool
hi did you enjoy that video well make
sure to check out more of those videos
in the the video description below or on
the links on the screen see you later